hello everyone so this toolkit is the
first one of tonight and I guess so the
dogs would be about atomic design and I
will go first and it's at least the five
W's of atomic design so let's start this
so hello everyone
ciao I'm Italian so hello ciao means I
don't know if you know where the word
may be never been in a restaurant I've
been served by an Italian waiter or
waiters and so you never heard the word
that means a low so as I said my name is
Ricardo and also as a result am Italian
and you know classic 11 start
stereotypes pasta pizza whatever I used
to I did like a similar talk like in my
previous company as a like an internal
talk and I also used to have like the
emoji over like a football but I remove
that because you know you know in the
last month there was like some games on
TV friendlies I don't care than I repent
so yeah so let's move on so that's why I
am so what I do so I'm a lead from 10
developer at Hackney Hackney Council
everyone in this room lives in Hackney
borough phew cool so I just joined
actually two weeks ago and it's being
like very very good so far it's a quite
interesting job and it's quite
interesting like council what we're
doing it's very like unique we're trying
to collaborate a lot with other councils
about so like with central government
and like companies that work with
central governments we try to build like
digital services that are kind of like
user driven so we're thinking about
users first more than about technology
and other stuff and we are trying to be
like very modern in terms of either
today we use we have like a manifesto we
have like an agile
lifecycle we are using like everything
from we're moving everything on the
cloud on a rock or in AWS we use like
test-driven development we do
programming
it's very very cool and very very modern
other councils like they don't try to
like do this kind of model stuff no
because they are able to but just
because you know it can be expensive at
you need to are people and stuff like
that and by its very goal I'm quite
quite excited of Johnny's company and
the City Council and
by the way we are hiring like soon more
front-end developers so if any of you is
looking for a job or you have a job but
you want something better and you know
after this talk and at the end or like
in the pub come and have a chat with me
and especially you know minorities and
representing groups from it something's
very important so you know feel free to
come and have a chat with me so
regarding like that's my role you know
Ali from the developer but like what do
I do
like I call myself like you know
juggling like a CSS architect it's not
real like you know role but because it's
I love CSS so much and I care about like
writing semantics and accessible HTML
and surprised I'm not actually J's
developer so I mean a J's meetup but I
don't do Jas I can do Jas but I never
wrote like any react or angular or view
and you know you can still be a
front-end developer and not be like a.j
as developer and that's why I like you
know sometimes like I think I prefer to
call myself a front-end designer that's
something that actually this explains
why well what it is like it's you know
is the personal in a way builds like a
bridge between like design and
development and this kind of like role
this name was invented by a guy called
Brad frost who's also like the inventor
of atomic design so surprised and also
scary Maji this is my first ever public
talk so you know press yourself and you
know thank you and you know if at some
point like I panic and I run away it's
not your fault it's me
so thank you in advance and yeah there's
a little presentation so let's start and
let's talk about atomic design as the
diode said I was talking about atomic
design consider like the five W's of
atomic design the fact that be something
that usually get used like in Germany so
my investigation so how to like
otherwise a topic and stuff like that so
the first it's the who so who invented
atomic design and as I said was invented
by this guy but Frost who also as a
lovely dog piss dog and so breast Frost
is a front-end developer is an American
guy and is a very good developer
very nice guy I never met him but I know
someone who met him told me is a nice
guy so I guess it's a nice guy and so he
came like few years ago about out with
these like concept of atomic design and
these like methodology about atomic
design he even like developed a tool
that can be used for using the
methodology of atomic design called
patent lab but we're not going to talk
about that tonight and yeah also he he
wrote a book about about odami designed
that probably you should all read it's
digital and also it's physical copy if
you want a physical copy comes with a
nice sticker if you want a physical copy
so this is the guy this is dog so the
what so what is it is atomic design so
we can have like a very simple
illustration that can explain everything
and it's this one but obviously doesn't
make any sense for you probably right
now because I have to explain what it is
so I will go back to this once explained
a bit more about the what and I'm pretty
sure this will be more clear full of you
so let's start from the first one so the
atoms so what is an atom so an atom it's
small and independent component and what
I mean with that is that we you know
we're the design of a page or the
product of an app and we break down the
design into components and so what we
end up doing is not like we design pages
or with design screens we just design
and build like components and if we do
that instead of like doing pages or
other kind of like big monolithic stuff
but we do it's like we're able to avoid
a repetition and confusion and you know
what this brings us at the end it just
like we can design a build less stuff
and quicker because you know it's less
confusing it's more clear it's like
smaller pieces and you know what you get
it is kind of like very nice gift
Sanjeev give and you know let's watch
this again
like you know it's looping so we can
have a look what it is so this is like
all atoms they combine all together in
molecules and Dinoco
opponent like Danna template and then a
page so let's go back to this one
again so we have atoms molecules
organism templates and pages so if we go
back to this again
so now tones for example here we can see
that three atoms you know like the label
like you know that the data form and the
button and then that form altogether you
know it's a molecule this because it's
like an independent component Li by
itself and then it's part with other
molecules that can be in this case like
the other and then of and there will be
like the fool like I guess top bar we
can call it and then the top bar it's
the organism and then we combine
organism together and with that we build
templates and then once we have
templates we can add like VL data to
those templates and we build pages and
if you think about that like it's a
quite simple concept in a way it just
requires I guess breaking down at the
beginning like what you have and
thinking about like breaking down in
this concept so this is what the what so
what we're doing and what is economic
design so let's go next so the why why
we're doing this like we know what we
have to do and explain it quickly
what is designed about why we're doing
like what we're gaining with this so
we're doing this because we should
design and build components and not
pages as I said before and the reason
why we should do that it's because today
and not just today as in 2018 today I
guess in the last I don't know 10 years
probably on the web like we design and
build a lot of everything we design a
build for a lot of devices and with this
under built for those scenarios
you know devices your phone your tablet
your computer your fridge because fridge
they can browse the internet or know why
your cards if you're reaching a fever
Tesla I don't know good for you and you
know different scenarios different
websites because we you might be a
branded product you have different
website for your different like branding
the different products different apps
because can be in different devices
different tiles and stuff like that
so we have situation like that's all
these things that way to consider
where these like millions of devices and
these pictures very old I'm pretty sure
now it's like 10 times more than this as
in like the amount of devices that every
one of us like use so then we design and
build a lot of pages because sometimes
which is different from different
devices different use and then we want
to avoid like confusion mistakes message
situation like we want to avoid
something like these as in like these
are buttons from same website and you
know this doesn't make any sense like
what you're different there's no like
consistency there's no like same color
like I don't know padding spacing font
like everything is different this is not
branding probably they'll code it in a
different way so it's very confusing
we're like blowing the code we're
rewriting things again this is no idea
for sure so then the next the next step
is like the where so where we should
implement these atomic design
methodology and we should apply this
methodology in our design as in like you
know you have your Photoshop Illustrator
sketch figma I don't know what the news
for designing Dreamweaver I don't know
adopt XP whatever in the browser maybe
it isn't in the browser you f to apply
these methodologies like you know just
design is more components just like
design items and then there's n
molecules like Dom design pages like
design like the small things and when
you have all this more components like
build pages out of these designs these
more components that you have if you
know if someone comes to you and asking
oh can I see a full page of this design
you just like combine all the all these
components that you design and you can
bend them together
and the page is there it's quick and
it's better like to kind of like manage
and maintain and these goes also like
for you know apply this methodology also
in your development so when you like
developing something like don't build
like by hand your index dot HTML page or
your index dot J's page like build all
the different components individually
and each of them they will have their
own style and their own structure
and then combine them together to build
like the pages that you need and you
know you can do that on the fly I don't
know depends about your solution or you
can build them like you know just needed
but it would be so much easier thing
cover like I don't know Lego like you
have small bricks and then you build
full thing together so you just have to
in a way like build the small bricks
first and it's so much easier and it's
kind of like I don't know as I said like
you avoid a lot of mistakes in the
process and it's way more like tiring
and tedious and stuff like that so the
last of the five W's maybe the last it's
the the when so when we should think and
kind of like apply this methodology of
atomic design and I would say
immediately like as soon as possible all
the time like thinking atomic design
like every time think that like you
should break down things in small pieces
and you should always think like oh this
mold let's say small atom that would be
like on a simple button like this thing
should be like consistent in throat
you'll design like if I don't know this
error comes to you designers know
designing thinking about this concept of
dummy design comes to you and shows you
like a page with two buttons that do the
same thing but they look different then
question that say like why this is
different like this should be the same
atom why this is not the same and if
it's different doesn't it'll be
different
is it like a variation of the same
button the same atom or not so I try to
simplify and unify your pieces of your
designs in a very like small bits in
atoms and just go there and like from
there just like build up so what's next
next is actually the last thing this
time for real before I was not being
honest so it's the house so as I said
before you know the five W's it's what's
being using journalism and investigation
sometimes if the five W's and the H so
the the H is how so we know the who the
what the why the one aware about how we
implement like this methodology of
atomic design and we implemented like
building style guides
pattern library design systems whatever
when you go like I'm pretty sure like
the the other folks the like they will
talk after me they will talk about this
like in more
more details and you know you can use
whatever technology you want like
building react in view in angular
personally I like just to build in
simple like HTML and CSS and JavaScript
just because in my experience I've been
working in companies like agencies but
also like product companies where an
agency there would be multiple projects
and in product companies there will be
multiple products they are not using
kind of like the same coding like the
same like programming languages now
using the same frameworks so I find like
for me it was easier and kind of like
most time-saving to build like kind of
just simple HTML CSS and JavaScript and
then with that didn't just apply that
code in ever kind in any kind of like
already built like framework or
application stuff like that obviously
that's my preference and so that's why
I'm talking about just like this generic
concept and personally if I want to use
a tool I use something called fractal
it's very similar to pattern lapatinib
as I said before was the tool invented
by Brett Frost fractal is being invented
by a guy from clear:left he left is a
digital agency basing here in UK in
Brighton and at the moment fractal is
not being actually maintained
he's on version 1 by still like very
functional and very flexible and I love
it it's very simple to use and you can
use whatever you want and again like for
me is that before like just doing like
simple HTML just case for me is like the
console of like an MVP I start with the
simple stuff and then if after that you
want to build in react yeah I just go on
top on that like implement some react
after that you want to do something even
more cool there's some people
experimenting with building like
lifestyle guides as in like when you
design a tramatic that when you say
something's capturing figma goes into
your life like style guide and that's
what's amazing
partying that's like the next step and
it's up to you one thing that I like is
one last thing that I know this white
building likes Tigers and pattern
libraries and implementing the atomic
design methodology is like that
sometimes you have as I said a you know
the smallest component is like an atom
an atom could be a button could be a
Abel suffered that to be header and
sometimes you have like something that's
below that level is I don't know your
phone's your color palette your I don't
know your your spacing like the stuff
like that so how we should we should
have this kind of like bits in our in
our components and how do we call them
because I know atoms as in like they
don't like your fonts is not a component
that lives in a page so and I call that
particles I'm not sure if I invented
that
probably not but having it's cool
because it's before returns and it works
and you know thank you that's all
[Applause]